[Music]
everybody tell you what I do about music
on all my social media one of the big
problems is rights music rights so you
don't want to rip anybody's music off
that's so uncool
and often acquiring rights takes a long
time so if your riff if you're ripping
out a lot of social media like ask mr.
wonderful this episode maybe it's better
to record your own music and you know
piano maybe guitar whatever so what I've
done is I've built a little home studio
in here very simple monitor amp I've got
a junior fender blues which is a great
little you know recording so a little
you know bluesy kind of thing reverb on
it over here a 24 track very inexpensive
now and a drum machine because you need
something to kind of get in the groove
with so I'm gonna record sort of a
little something like that maybe some
kind of an uplifting kind of you know
bridge between questions or whatever
where we need some drums so I'm gonna
just let you hear the drums instead of a
little track I've chosen little volume
[Music]
[Music]
that's gonna do so you got foot pedals
here you turn them off and on so what we
want to do is we want to lay down those
drums and maybe do it at the same time
recording the track people just do a
couple of stereo tracks so what I got to
do for that is I got to put the phones
on because I don't want to have the drum
beat bleed in to the mics that are
recording the fender blues amp because I
like the real sound I don't want to go
into the board directly I don't know if
you guys what you do when you record but
I don't like a guitar directly in your
board I want to go through an amplifier
with that little dirt I like the dirt of
the you know the tubes that's a tube amp
so what I got to do here is put on the
phones to hear the drums leave one ear
open so I can hear that Yap all right so
I'm gonna turn off the monitor for now
so here we record this and we'll play it
back afterwards and listen to it
[Music]
all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's the one everybody welcome to
another episode of ask mr. wonderful and
this one I'm really excited about why
because it's about lamb would love it's
Valentine's Day what can I say so we got
all kinds of questions now remember I've
got a position about this I love love
nobody loves more than I love love love
just is fantastic and it's a fantastic
time of your life falling in love is one
of the great human experiences however
having said that love and marriage and
family are also about money you know the
number one reason for people's divorce
is not indiscretions its attention of
financials that's what hurts financial
pressure is what breaks up marriages you
know not infidelity over half the
marriages that fall apart between five
and seven years happened because of
tremendous financial stress so you want
to avoid that we're gonna be talking
about that today but I don't want to
take away from valentine's day you know
I love Valentine's Day no question about
it
so let's get going with the questions
here who do we have first I've got John
John what do you got
hi mr. wonderful thanks for your awesome
and interesting program I'm enjoying the
new mr. wonderful unplugged on YouTube
for Matt I'm John this question is about
nuptials as in pre and post I'll start
with a quick backstory I got married
nine years ago and we now have a six
year old daughter because we hadn't
taken the time to write up nuptials in
one form or another it gradually became
a source of energy draining dysfunction
which sapped years of our time
productivity and Happiness we're now in
the process of divorce my question is
this twofold isn't such family
dysfunction a flag for business partners
and investors and - do you require
entrepreneurs to have nuptials in place
with their spouse thanks for your
thoughts you know this is a really good
question that's a bit of a debbie downer
on Valentine's Day you know but you got
to talk about money what can I say
prenup shows post mushrooms let's start
with
the great thing about a prenuptial
agreement is it forces the truth out
you've got to be thinking about the
future you want to find out something
about somebody that's really important
before you marry them and that's why
pretty much your agreement really helps
it gets you both to the table it has
you're talking about money something's
very important in marriage I know your
your fork and say I don't need a prenup
I love this woman so much I love this
man so much I love a significant person
so much whoever you're coupling with I
don't care but what I do care about is
your money and frankly I'd rather see
you get a prenuptial agreement because
basically you're joining two people
together and I've always said it makes
you in a prenup agreement discuss your
future plans about what you can do in
finance what are your goals you're gonna
buy a house the next five years you're
planning on having kids what about their
college all that stuff and you really
want to find out about your significant
other have they been bankrupt before
what's the history the family is a
brother a compulsive gambler has
somebody been to jail I know this is
tough love stuff but frankly you got to
deal with it
that's what I'm saying and a prenup
forces all that stuff so yes - prenup
now once you have a child you have
formed a family that is actually a
business because you got to support it
you have to finance you have to be the
financial pillar whether I don't care
who's working somebody's got to work
maybe both of you work but at the end of
the day you've got to support the family
and one of the great strengths of
families and why they were founded was
to gather food and sustain each other
and in today's modern society that
includes having a job and having some
free cash flow so at the end of the day
you've got to consider that and we you
know really post nuptials are forced by
the court at the end of the day if you
have a family and a child to support
by the time you go through the ringer of
divorce which I find so troubling you're
gonna have to deal with supporting that
child into adulthood but I don't wish
that on anybody think about money before
you couple it's important it's always
sitting at the table and remember I love
love but I love money too and so will
you it takes the stress
out of marriage if you're well-funded
you don't have to fight about money you
can fight about something else
but remembering that money is the reason
that most marriages fail you want to get
it out of the way and you want to really
think hard about who you're marrying
love that question John let's move on
you know I don't wanna be negative on
Saint doubt that on Valentine's Day come
on I want to be positive let's get a
nice question here all right we've got
by the way I'm on Miami Beach and the
helicopters are flying by with all the
ads on the planes too but I love the
sound of that outdoors this is well this
is gonna be interesting
Stacy let's go hi mr. wonderful this is
Stacy I'm an expat living in Hong Kong
here's my question for you my fiance and
I have been engaged for about three
years and we finally picked a date one
thing we've been fighting about is the
registry we've lived together for about
three years now we don't need anything
for the house but we do need money now
my fiance thinks it's tacky to ask for
money from guests what do you think
thank you mr. wonderful Oh Stacy ha ha
I'm so happy you know I'm really really
happy to hear you want to buy crap for
the house you want to get money that
makes a lot of sense and a marriage you
want to save some money retired dead
everything else I've got a solution for
you it's one of my shark tank companies
honey fund honey fund is a wedding
registry online service used by hundreds
of thousands of couples just like you I
know this is sandwich from shameless
promotion but frankly it's gonna solve a
problem for you here's how it works your
guests coming your marriage or even
those that want to just gift you
something because you're having your
special day go to honeyfund calm and buy
from a wide range of offerings there but
here's the secret sauce the special is
Jeunesse equi you don't have to take the
gift you can take the cash
yippee I youkai yay solves problems for
everybody that's why honey funds so
popular your guests get to gift you
something that they think is heartfelt
and you take the cash aroni instead
isn't that wonderful now that was a
great question and it makes me feel warm
and fuzzy anyways thank you Sarah mine
golus is the CEO of honey fund I'm glad
I get to talk about it because she's
done a wonderful job helping people just
like you Stacey
so check out honey fun calm because I
love love great question
let's move on next on the hit parade is
Bethany ah all right
hi mr. wonderful my name is Bethany and
I have a question that I'm hoping you
can help me out with
I was recently offered a promotion at my
current workplace it's a really good
promotion they'd be promoting me to VP
and I'd be making about double what I am
now the problem is that it would result
in me working more hours at work which
is something that I'm okay with but my
husband basically said that if I took
their promotion he would leave me which
is obviously not something that I want
he thinks that it would be a lot better
for a family if I stayed home and raised
our children so my question to you is
what should I do I take the promotion is
a lot more important for family is there
something that I can say to my husband
to kind of sell him on my point so
thanks for taking the time to listen and
love watching you on YouTube
Bethany Kim are you kidding that's
outrageous because you're moving ahead
and you're advancing he's jealous that's
what it sounds like to me listen if you
are the breadwinner in the family then
you should March on and take this
opportunity and provide for your family
come on what's the matter with him
that's complete [ __ ] I'm really
pissed to hear that that's ridiculous
you're a couple you work together you
solve problems like this knowing that
marriage is really confounded with
financial problems for many many people
here you are doubling your income yeah
you got to work a little extra harder
but you're doing it for both of you
what's the name of that guy I'm gonna
call him up this is ridiculous do not
take that answer don't let him threaten
love and separation because of your
success you guys have to work this thing
out that is absolute crap Ola and by the
way there's many many families today
where the other the significant other
the wife or the husband do a switch
because they find themselves in a career
path that's faster one stays at home if
you're gonna have kids you got to
support them and the other goes and
works or you both work harder and save
more cuz ones created more wealth away
you're doing you stay on track girl you
keep going come on
d'un never let somebody browbeat you out
of a jump I'm pissed
I know I know it's Valentine's Day but
I'm pissed I'm just that question really
pisses me off tell your husband mr.
Wonderful's pissed off and that's not
good that's absolutely outrageous I'm I
got to calm down
oh my goodness anyways go girl go get
the money in advance you're gonna end up
the CEO of that company one day it
sounds like to me what I'd never mind
okay let's move on calm down calm down
all right
here we have Ben Ben what do you got hey
mr. wonderful I'm wondering if you think
that couples should split bills equally
My partner and I make significantly
different amounts of money and it always
becomes really awkward when we have to
talk about finances so I'm just
wondering your thoughts
Ben great question you know I wrote a
book about all these kinds of things
called men women and money you should
check it out but I'm gonna tell you what
I said in the book because it's one of
the biggest issues you know when you get
coupled up you really got to start
thinking about finance I want both
partners to have their own bank accounts
and then have a third that they share I
always want people to have financial
dependency so they keep their own bank
accounts they keep their own credit
ratings I don't care for your whole life
you have to have your own credit rating
because you never know if what happens
in marriage stuff happens so you got to
keep your own credit rating whether
you're the man the woman or the
significant other doesn't matter to me
but regarding the costs of living
together the rent the things you buy the
food entertainment travel vacations you
got a share and that's why you have the
third account you fund it equally
particularly if you're both making the
same amount of money you fund it equally
and you put a credit card on there a
separate credit card for that account
that when you're spending together you
can track I love to do things separately
but that joint account pays for all the
things you do together but you keep your
own dough and you decide what the
amounts gonna be it's a 2000 each amun
3,000 instruments whatever it is you
work it out and that's the joint account
but you keep your own credit rating
that's number one always always
important I've loved these questions but
I got one more thing I want to talk
about me and this is really important
this is not about money
if you've been with somebody for a long
time or even it's just started dating
and you really like them and you're
thinking about them the most important
thing to do is write them a handwritten
note a card even if you have to make it
yourself even wouldn't have any money
just the thought that counts it's more
powerful than taking them out for dinner
or buy them flowers you can do that too
but a handwritten note expressing
exactly how you feel even if it's on a
piece of paper fold in half now I go a
little higher end because I love a
company I've involved in and this is
another shameless promotion but it's for
love pop cards I love these cards let me
show you something ready boom look at
that isn't that cool that's a dragonfly
considered very lucky many cultures this
is the card I'm gonna give Linda my wife
on Valentine's Day there's this little
thing you pull out and you write your
note on it put it inside now people say
what you're giving your dragonfly yeah I
love it I love this dragonfly I just
love the way it folds up in the card
goes yeah yeah kaboom I think she'll
love it it's beautifully made but they
make all kinds of Valentine's cards to
the schmaltzy ones I don't like but I
like dragonflies what can I say anyways
check out love pop com for your
Valentine's card
but whatever it takes get something
written down and hand them that note
even if you don't buy a card it comes
from the heart and it really really is
powerful it's that one day to make your
memories mean something very special
say something about what you loved about
your significant other in the last year
put it down and writing hand them the
card with the date on it and the year
they'll keep it for the rest of their
lives trust mr. wonderful on this one
it's the most important thing you can do
this Valentine's Day
love all of you keep the great questions
coming
and remember la moda whoa whoa whoa whoa
I love love
[Laughter]
[Music]